Short and sweet number six. In a bediavad situation where a dairy utensil or dish was washed in a meat dishwasher with other meat dishes, then that dairy utensil or dish would have to be koshered. We do not have the leniencies that we relied on before when we were dealing with a sink.
In regards to buying coffee at a Starbucks or Dunkin' Donuts, we discussed how it's much more preferable to get a coffee at a Dunkin' Donuts for two reasons.
First of all, the Dunkin' Donuts chain and franchise is much more kosher conscience, and they prefer kosher products over non-kosher products.
Yad Tzoletisbo
If, however, the meat and dairy was next to the salt and was uncovered,
because we are afraid that the meat or the dairy got into the salt,
and the salt is now fleshyk or milchik, and salt is something which is used as parv,
and can be used with either type.
B'dievet, if a person already did it, they left the meat or dairy next to the salt, uncovered,
or a sugar dish, for example, would also be another example.
So then, b'dievet, the salt or the sugar is still parv,
as long as there is no meat or dairy visible inside of the salt.
In a situation where a person has meat next to dairy or dairy next to meat, so then again, if it's covered, so then it's totally permitted.
There's no concern that if it was covered, it got from one to the other.
In a situation where it was uncovered, the meat or the dairy was uncovered next to the other.
So that was in Makhloka, so Shulchan Aruch held that everything is still permitted.
However, the Ramah said, Likha Chila, this is something we should not do.
And B'di Yeved, we again say that everything is permitted as long as there's no visible mixing.
So again, the difference between the Shulchan Aruch and the Rama is that Shulchan Aruch says you can Lichad Chila, leave meat next to dairy, uncovered, while the Rama says that one should not do that.
Okay, in a situation where a person had salt kept in a meat dish, so then the Shulchan Aruch and the Taz both said that it can be used with dairy.
The Rama said it's praiseworthy not to use the salt that was kept in a meat dish with dairy.
However, in a situation where it was, it doesn't seem that the Rama would say, but it's a problem.
We then began the sugya of Stam Yeinam and Yayin Nesech.
So we explained that there's a very big difference between Yayin Nesech and Stam Yeinam.
Yayin Nesech is wine which was actually used as a libation for Avodah Zarah.
If that's the case, the wine is biblically, asr daraisah, prohibited to drink or get benefit from, even in the smallest amounts.
Stam Yeinam is wine which we do not know to have been used for Avodah Zarah.
However, it was wine which was either owned or touched by a non-Jew.
In that scenario, the Chachamim, our Rabbanon, enacted a Rabbinic Gezerah against drinking this wine and from benefiting from the wine.
There are two different reasons behind each of these prohibitions.
The prohibition from drinking the wine was in order to prevent intermarriage.
We don't want us getting too close to non-Jews and Chas HaSholam becoming intermarried with them.
So the Chachamim forbade drinking this wine which was touched or owned by a non-Jew.
And the Yisr of Hanna, the prohibition from benefiting it, was from its connection to Yayin Nesech.
And that's why they also forbade benefiting just like Yayin Nesech has as well.
And we will explain the next year the different applications nowadays.